foreign
hey everybody here we are again it's
another haunting Mondays yeah
it's funny uh Daniel Rowling says this
episode I don't remember whatsoever I
feel like this episode barely got played
on the reruns yeah I kind of feel like
that too when we were watching it
um yeah I didn't remember much I didn't
really remember anything about it which
is weird because it's on the disc like
with a bunch of other ones that I
remembered like pretty clearly it's a
well-made episode yeah so it's like I
didn't really understand like why I
didn't remember hardly anything about it
because it actually is like kind of
interesting and it's like kind of
distinctive yeah there's nothing none of
them else none of them none of the other
ones really like this yeah it has like a
distinctive title it has like a
distinctive kind of it's a possession
but it's not really a demon it's like a
ghost possession yeah yeah which kind of
goes back to like what I said before
that if you look at the Old Testament
the New Testament there's kind of a
disagreement about what a demon is in
the Old Testament a demon is a fallen
angel and there seems to be a couple
different groups you know some have been
chained in the Earth but then when you
read Christian materials especially like
Pauline type stuff or
um some gospel material
what they're talking about is a Roman
version of a demon which is the spirit
of an evil dead possessing people you
can take them out of pit you can cat
take them out of people and cast them
into pigs and you're exercising these
demons you know in the name of Jesus and
everything it seems to be that at least
yeah it seems to be that
at least some of the early Christian
Cults before the religion was canonized
seemed like they were
possession Cults or exorcism Cults is
that that seems to be the purpose of
Christianity throwing demons out in the
name of Jesus
some of them in the South are still like
that
let's make sense it makes sense so this
movie this episode is kind of like
talking about a very new testament I
guess you could say
spirits of the Evil Dead going into
people and trying to cast them out in
the name of Jesus I Think Jesus
and then um Hallelujah yeah and uh it
had a
unique Flair in this episode because it
was about a Puerto Rican Family living
in New York and then later on they moved
to Arizona
and in Arizona that you got some a good
desert action in the episode it's just
cool you know it's a cool episode yeah
Zach said is this the episode about the
Mexican drummer who moves into the
racist guy's house yeah well he's part
of American Puerto Rican and he's a
guitarist not a drummer
um but he's into the racist guy's house
and the racist ghost is still trying to
get him what it doesn't want him in the
house yeah it's like ooh we don't want
so I wonder if like if Whitey's had
moved in like would he not have haunted
anybody because he's like okay this is
acceptable what happened anyway you
think yeah because he's just just an
evil ghost yeah
it's like the one where the black goes
with chasing the white people out of the
house this is my house
they [ __ ] him out of his inheritance
because my theory was is that he was
actually he was actually the son of the
of that particular Plantation and he
gave it to his son it was would have
been the rightful Heir and the relatives
came and said oh no no no no no no no I
can see why he was mad yeah he chased
him out of his own house and then that
was a spooky episode with that
1800s black dude with that hat this is
my house you know [ __ ] with his white
eyes and [ __ ] you know
it's like yeah it's great yeah this is
your house bro this is your house
yeah you can have it yeah I didn't do it
man I wasn't even born then all right
I mean I kind of feel like maybe he if
you kind of explain the situation to him
and like yeah he said he could hang out
we gonna share this house yeah I mean
like that'd be cool that's okay just
like don't like creep up on me like in
the middle of the night like freak me
out and [ __ ] you go in the house and
I'll fix it up yeah that's like I think
that's I'll fix up your house
right so I think you could have come to
some kind of like cohabiting agreement
with the ghost in that case this one not
so much
this one not so much because I feel like
this ghost just wanted to be a dick yeah
you know he's just like he was angry in
life and he wanted to be like Angry in
the afterlife they never did establish
if he did actually like well I don't
know maybe I'm jumping ahead but they
never really established it whether he
really did commit suicide or not I guess
they implied that he kind of did but now
Zach says it's his understanding that
there's a form of exorcism in Judaism he
wants to know what that looks like I
don't know
because um
I'm going back and just in my head
trying to go through every time
demons were mentioned
in the Old Testament they're talking
about
the ones that knew the daughters of men
and gotten chained into the Earth
even Satan in the Book of Job is not a
demon he was free to roam Earth and go
to heaven because he was God's Chief
prosecutor he wasn't being punished it
was his job to go out and test people in
the Book of Job
so I I maybe well you know maybe the
Jews have a thing about the spirits of
the Evil Dead possessing people but it's
not in it's not in the uh
the deal our version of the Old
Testament was based on the Septuagint
which is the Greek version I think the
Torah has the most is mostly taken from
the Septuagint
but uh I don't know I have to see what
they'd have in their laws
maybe maybe in rabbitic texts or
something rabbitic tests there may be
some references to the spirits of the
Evil Dead possessing people but I don't
think it's in
in any of the real traditional Jewish
stories
can you think of anything
no no
I don't think they're in there
because
the god of the Old Testament is
basically a demiurge he's the God and
the devil and the devil combined into
one thing
you know
you follow his law or that's it I told
you don't touch that Covenant don't
touch that Ark
remember he just did touch the ark tried
to keep it from falling and was killed
all right it doesn't have anything to do
with right and wrong it was just about
obedience and keeping up with the
Covenant which is kind of like a
gangster Covenant I chose you you're
going to do what I say that's basically
what the Covenant was
Danny rolling said hopefully it's
nothing like the circumcision ritual
involving uh oops it disappeared old man
sucking on baby penis yeah pretty much
uh Zach says by the way Jenny I'm
working on a new story idea it's
basically a don't look now ripoff about
a hallucinating artist in Amsterdam but
I'm putting my own spin on it that
actually sounds really good I mean don't
look now is one of my very favorite
movies of all time
so yeah so like we were talking about
earlier even though we have
uh seasons one through seven on disk
right and we watched them all the time
we used to just like put them on and let
them play through and the disc that this
is on this is like the same disc I think
that like the last week's episode was on
as well but it's like for some reason
even though I remembered most of the
other ones on the disc I did not
remember any a single thing about this
one and it's really weird because it's a
good episode and you would think that it
would stand out but it just like I don't
know why I didn't remember anything
about it like I'm watching it going I do
not remember a single thing about this
and even though I know we watched it
probably multiple times
kalon Higgins said I didn't think people
in Jewish cultures believed in ghosts
were Spirits I think some I think like
maybe some sects of it do I can't think
of anything in in the Old Testament
where a ghost is mentioned yeah
when people died they went to shio they
didn't even go to heaven they just went
to the Grave
some people were translated into heaven
as kind of like an ultimate reward but
heaven in the Old Testament doesn't seem
to be ever been made for human beings it
was made just for angels and the Gods
is that going to Mount Olympus basically
so I don't think they're receiving I
don't remember anything about any Heaven
mentioned or any even hell mentioned in
the Old Testament it's just the shield
the grave
I don't remember any ghosts
I don't remember any ghosts matches if
somebody can remember us an Old
Testament story where ghosts are
mentioned
you know you can drop it in the comment
section I'm trying to think of one I
don't think anybody talks to a ghost or
sees a ghost in all those stories
Danny Rowling said they believe in
Golems yeah that's not quite the same
that's not quite a ghost I mean it's
kind of along the same lines more like a
Frankenstein I guess so
but it's still I mean I guess you're
bringing clay to life like the way God
did it yeah with like magic essentially
it's kind of like the same thing
kind of sort of I mean to me it I don't
know it all seems along the same Spectra
it's not that ghost of it it's not a
ghost of a dead person though yeah right
I know
but I'm just saying that as far as like
Supernatural stuff goes it's not really
that different to me
you know
um so yeah do you want to get into
talking to this episode or do you want
to like talk about some other stuff no
all I'm going to say is that ghosts as
far as I know ghosts and demons as we
know them spirits of evil dead people is
Greco-Roman I don't think it's Jude I
don't think it's Jewish
I don't think you know if somebody May
correct me but I'm just trying to buy
memory because I hadn't really thought
of it
by memory I don't remember any stories
like that
in the Old Testament that involved
ghosts or anything like spirits of evil
people evil dead people
I don't recall anything like that
it's not even
it's not even brought up
you know what I mean so I hadn't hadn't
thought of it
okay
I mean
this is just
I don't like the this is just an
interesting episode because it's like
possession but it's not it's demonic
possession it's like it's supposedly a
person that lived at one point and then
they died and then their ghost was the
[ __ ] and came and like possessed
somebody's body because they were a jerk
yeah and as far as I know that is a
Christian concept for going back to
Greco-Roman period yeah yeah
um okay so this was season four episode
11.
Casa de los Muertos and uh it first came
out in 2007. now I was interested
because the guy who's like at the center
of this not the guy that was possessed
because it was actually some that was
possessed but like the dad this is um
he's kind of like a famous person like
he's pretty famous like in certain
circles he's passed away now sadly he
died in 2019.
but uh his name is Eddie Benitez and he
was actually
um kind of a Latin jazz and a world
music guitarist and I guess he was
something like a child prodigy and um
you know he played later on with like
Barry White like you know Tito Puente
stuff like that I guess he formed a band
when he was like a teenager so like I
said he was kind of he cut albums when
he was younger
um interestingly here's a fun fact that
I saw on his Wikipedia page that he was
actually the first Latin artist to
perform at CBGB in 1976. this isn't that
so he must have been a kid then yeah
because I think he yeah well now I guess
he would have been a kid I think he
would have been 20. I think he was born
in
1956. so yeah but like I said he did a
lot of stuff like when he was younger
now interestingly on this show
they kind of like
um Glide over the fact that it's like he
did a lot of music stuff when he was
younger like when he was a teenager in
his 20s but then on the show like a
haunting it says he took a break when he
was 23 and you know go like started a
family finished College stuff like that
what they didn't mention I'm not really
sure why they didn't mention this he
took a break when he was 23 because he
developed Hodgkin's lymphoma
like he got cancer at 23. and he
obviously got over it but that was why
he took a break mainly it seemed like so
it just seemed odd that they didn't
bring that up but that was like
something that I found out like on
outside sources I just thought that was
like an interesting thing that they
didn't mention you know what I mean and
um
I think that's kind of like
when he started reflecting more on kind
of like spiritual stuff and everything
like that because it does say on his
page that he had like visions and all
these kind of things uh throughout his
life and actually when he went back into
music in 2003
um they did mention that he went back
and did like this private concert and
stuff like in 2003 like trying to
relaunch his solo career but what they
didn't mention on the show and again I
don't know why is that apparently
allegedly
um some of the people at the show said
that they saw like Angels or like
entities or something like that like
performing on stage with him so there
was that too but they didn't mention
that on the show but I just thought I
would mention it because I found it uh
on the outside and I just thought it
would be it was kind of interesting uh
but yeah like I said he's um he's on
this show he's interviewed his wife has
interviewed his son is interviewed and
like one or two of the um paranormal
team that investigated our interviewed
as well but as I I said um you know
Eddie Benitez he actually died in 2019
when he was 63 years old I'm presuming
that his son whose name is also Eddie's
Eddie Jr I'm presuming that he's still
alive but I don't really know
so uh so yeah so we start out with Eddie
as a kid
and he him and his mom like are living
in Brooklyn now I think that according
to the Wikipedia page he actually moved
to Brooklyn with his family when he was
nine prior to that he was born in Puerto
Rico but then like his dad works for
some company that um had branches like
in other countries so he actually lived
in Europe for a little while like I
think he lived in Italy and [ __ ] like
that and then eventually like when he
was nine or ten years old then they
moved to Brooklyn they didn't mention
his dad in the show they made it look
like a single mom situation but I don't
think it was
so um his mom's name is Carmen and
apparently when he was growing up Carmen
was very well known in this neighborhood
for being like a spiritual healer type
of person and
um you know being able to kind of like
cast out demons from people uh and
things of that nature
so on the particular episode
um he's think he's talking about one
time back in 1976 like I said even
though
it's interesting because as I said they
showed they said specifically on the
show that this happened in 1976 and then
the reenactor that is showing him like
showed him like as a kid like he looked
maybe 14 15 something like that but in
real life I think he would have been
like 20 because I'm pretty sure he was
born in 1956 maybe it was 1959
I can't remember now but it's like I
think that he was like a little bit
older than like what they showed on
there
but so in 1976 he's like he remembers he
was sitting out on his front steps or
whatever
and two guys are come walking down the
street and they're holding this third
guy in between him who's just like
screaming and violent and like smacking
out at him and like acting all [ __ ]
crazy like uh who and he's clearly like
they you know they think he's possessed
right
so they're bringing him to Carmen to see
what's the matter with him and see if
she can like Purge the demon or whatever
so apparently like carbon just goes
right down there and like puts her hand
on his head and he goes down on his
knees and he's like help me help me blah
blah that his eyes go all [ __ ] white
and [ __ ] like that now I do like the
white eye like the white contact demon
kind of thing in these I just feel like
it looks really cool
but um but yeah so he basically like
flashes the white eyes at him and she's
like all right well you got to bring him
inside because you know we can't do this
out here on the street that would just
be like specifically call the cops
probably
so she brings the dude inside and she
does like a kind of well I use a kind of
I guess it's an actual exorcism like on
him it's just not the kind of exorcism
that you would normally see like in the
movies but she basically takes holy
water and she's like rubbing it all over
his head or whatever and then she puts
his hands like over a glass of water
because apparently that's like trapping
the ghost somehow like in the water well
they're not aquatic see I yeah you could
put a ghost that's a land ghost yeah
it's a land goes
totally neutralized I said what happens
if you like put if you purge the spirit
and then put it in the glass of water
and then somebody accidentally drinks
that yeah you don't drink that one
that's the demon water yeah yeah
what happens if instead of water you use
like pickle juice
yeah see I have so many questions or
like Kool-Aid or vodka pickle juice
pickles comes out of there he's pissed
off
maybe ghosts like pickle juice we don't
know see that's what I mean but I have
so many questions about it
Hugo's talking about what do you say he
said all abrahamic religions have ghosts
and souls and everything I don't I don't
I don't really recall any mention of any
kind of ghosts or souls in any of the
Old Testament stories
I don't even remember anybody being
visited by a ghost I mean I could be
wrong
but I believe all the uh saving Souls
from hell and [ __ ] like that is a
Christian invention because it's a copy
of Greek stuff
I don't I don't think the Jews had that
only thing I remember is that they they
went to the Grave which is sheol or kind
of like Darkness or Gloom
which would be kind of like
kind of like the place where the Titans
were stored in in Greek religion
yeah there's no promise of any kind of
reward for fulfilling the Ten
Commandments and and be and and
um no reward really for upholding your
part of the covenant not on the
individual basis but on a tribal basis
like Israel would gain from it but not
so much you as an individual I may be
wrong but I'm just trying to go back
through my memories of Old Testament
stories and I don't remember any ghosts
or Spirits or Souls ever being mentioned
in them
I may be wrong but I don't believe it's
mentioned
I don't think their understanding of
religion was the same as Christian
concepts of religion of getting
salvation and going to heaven and
getting a reward and all that it's
unclear whether or not you're even
supposed to go to heaven in Christianity
seems to be also you go to go to show
the grave
and then when Jesus comes back during
the during the tribulation
the uh the saved dead or re they're
somehow given new bodies and then later
on they inherit a new kingdom on Earth
in other words they're like they're
given Eden back there isn't any uh
promise of going to heaven that's
something that churches seem to have
made up
I don't think that's mentioned
more about getting Eden restored on on
earth and the kingdom of God
Big Jewel Jerusalem in the middle of the
Earth and [ __ ]
it's right there in Revelations
Zach says for some reason an episode I
always remember is the one where the
Mormons are haunts in the attic and all
the [ __ ] is flying around her in The
Possession which yeah I kind of remember
that one I don't remember which one it's
called though
um Danny Rowling said great head of hair
on the actor that played the father yeah
actually like both somebody
um the actor that played the dad was
like actually a good looking dude and
the actor that played the sun like
during one scene I was like oh my God
it's kylo Ren yeah he looked like just
like Adam Driver yeah they showed him
and they were good looking guys yeah
yeah yeah yeah they were I mean the sun
yeah the sun was good like the real son
was like a good looking he had that
Latin lover haircut
[ __ ] if you go back this log and
[ __ ] party back there you know that's
I'll steal your girlfriend it's the
Satchel haircut Sancho I'm stealing your
girlfriend probably yeah yeah give me
that guitar give me a rose
yeah yeah bottle of wine yeah
I mean you know oh yeah I can see it I
could see it man's gotta have his game
you know
sure Rico Suave
[Laughter]
swab they definitely were but yeah
seriously the actor that played not so
much the real son
um but the actor playing the sun looked
a lot like especially in some from some
angles and some scenes he really did
look like [ __ ] Adam Driver in the
Star Wars movies he looks like kylo Ren
like it was just it was uncanny like
really
um but yeah so where was I okay so um so
we were talking about like the two hands
over the over the water which is
supposed to like trap or weaken the
spirit I guess and keep it from escaping
so you're kind of like holding it in
stasis but then comes the coup de grass
if you want to call it that you
basically get another glass of water not
the same one you get another glass of
water and a plate and then you put the
glass of water like and you put the
plate on top and flip it over and then
you put it on the dude's head and tap it
three times and that's supposed to like
knock the demon into the water or it's
supposed to trap the demon between the
cup and the plate
so I'm like well what happens when you
inevitably have to wash those dishes
yeah
I mean maybe it's just a bury it like
that maybe yeah they didn't really say I
was like what's the follow-up on this
yeah I need to know reading too much
into it but that's that's my whole
magical thinking that's my whole thing
though yeah well because well the thing
about it if you've thought about the
ritual to that extent it's like this is
why we're doing this we're trapping the
demon in between the glass and the plate
and you know the fact that you're put
you put water in the glass so that it's
like water is representing the demon
being trapped in there like I get where
they're where they're coming from with
that but then I was just kind of like
well yeah but what happens after that
though like if you presume that the
demon is trapped in there like then what
do you do with it I'm sure they have you
got to burn it now or you gotta bury it
like you said with like some [ __ ]
symbols and [ __ ] on it or I'm sure they
had a way that's what I'm saying so I
they must have thought of that like the
follow up so I want to know what that is
I'm just saying
you know that's all because obviously
they thought of all the details up to
that so you think but yeah so you put it
on the person's head and you're like
hitting it and like you know
so um so Eddie sees his mom do that like
to this guy and apparently purges the
demon uh so you know bam it's all it's
all fixed
now so one night they're still at this
point we're still in 1976.
so he got discovered like in real life I
don't know if they mentioned this on the
show but he actually did get discovered
I think in a battle of the bands like
when he was a teenager and he got
discovered by like a um you know like a
record company executive or whatever and
he got signed to a contract
so he was making an album
so he's at the studio one night uh you
know working on the album and he him and
the sound engineer producer whatever
like they go out and the producer pays
for a cab like to take him home so he
gets in the back seat of the cab but
then the cab driver starts driving the
wrong way because he's like hey bro like
Brooklyn is that way and the cab
driver's just like la la not listening
to you blah blah blah like not like
turning around and he's like dude what
the [ __ ] like where are you going and he
just won't answer like the cab driver
won't answer like every time he asks
them like where the [ __ ] he's going and
then finally like the guy like turns
around like toward him and makes like a
real scary like demon face like he makes
that creepy like two big smile like his
eyes go away like like that and uh Eddie
is understandably like freaked out and
he's just like yep gonna get the [ __ ]
out of this car right now so he gets out
I don't know how he got home afterward
because who the [ __ ] knows where he was
they didn't have Uber back then so I'm
assuming he just called another cab and
then went home because he was going in
the opposite direction
so um so yeah so he's like holy [ __ ] the
cab driver was [ __ ] whatever so he
finally gets home and he tells his mom
about this whole situation and she said
oh well it's no big because you probably
just have the same gift as me it runs on
our family
um she's like I hate to tell you but
you're just gonna see this kind of [ __ ]
like your whole life because we're gonna
see ghosts and demons and that's just
what we do
um so she's like I guess you just saw
your first demon everybody remembers
their first time seeing the first demon
uh so yeah so she's like well you better
just get used to it and she says well
the dead can't hurt you so don't be
afraid you just have to become
accustomed to seeing them because you're
just gonna see them all the time
now as I mentioned uh the show said it's
you know because he's doing his music
career like when he was like a teenager
and like into his early 20s the show
said that he took a break from music at
23 but doesn't mention you know that he
had cancer and I don't know how long it
took him to get over that but he
eventually did on the show um it says
that he finished College he got married
his wife's name was Murda and she's
Myrna and she's on the show as well and
um they have a son whose name is Eddie
Jr and he was also on the show
so then it skips ahead to 2003
when Eddie has decided to get back into
music and he kind of like goes on a tour
now in 2004 his mom dies and a year
after that Eddie and his family decide
they're going to move from New York City
like in Brooklyn to Tempe Arizona now he
figured they wanted to do this because
he's like well it'll be closer to La
it'll be closer to Las Vegas because I
guess you've been playing some shows out
there so it's closer to some places
where you'd want if you want to be like
a have a music career or whatever so he
just thought that would be easier
so um before they move like while
they're loading up the truck there's a
shot where he sees a guy like walking
down the street like in front of their
Brownstone or whatever and then he sees
another guy walking in the opposite
direction who walks right through the
first guy so they're like meant to imply
that it's like oh yeah he can still see
ghosts like after all this time so he
just sees dead people walking around all
the time which I can't imagine that must
be like a real pain in the ass because
you like I said you think that there
would be like ghosts everywhere yeah it
would you would just be shoulder just
like wall-to-wall [ __ ] ghosts you'd
just be constantly like that because
there's be dead [ __ ] people
everywhere I would think so it's like if
that's if you could see them
you would just really have to tone
everything out because it's like you
feel like you were never by yourself
that you're always ghosts like [ __ ]
lurking around the [ __ ] every time
you like go to the bathroom it's like
ghosts standing in the shower or go
standing in the corner [ __ ] like that
that's all fun games
that's not what they're talking about
what they're talking about is they're
talking about a universe very much like
in the movie Frighteners
where a person dies
and they if they don't go to the light
and go to the go into the Afterlife one
way or the other they didn't go don't go
to the Heavenly Realms or or hellish
realms they're kind of temporarily stuck
in in well yeah to where they died but
there would still be a [ __ ] ton of them
around though maybe maybe it depends I
mean you know hypothetically yeah in in
um
in in Frighteners they're kind of sh the
they said that well every year or so
you're given an opportunity you'll see a
portal open up
haven't had like a near-death experience
and like an out-of-body experience once
and another spontaneous Obe
probably first of all a lot of that
stuff is based upon real occult [ __ ] and
observations that people made over a
long time a period of time in The
Frighteners that's actually a pretty
good interpretation of some of the stuff
that I saw
um
the idea that it would open up on a
timetable no
what they're hinting at it
is or what they're talking about is is
more like when you get into a certain
mindset eventually you'll be able to
leave you'll see it you'll see an
opportunity to leave you might get into
that mindset once every year or so
that's what they're talking about it's
not like it's on a timer or anything
so it could be that you'll have a a lost
soul kind of connected to the place of
their death and the around you know the
surrounding circumstance but with each
given year we with as every year passes
the chances of them still being there
would decline that's that's probably
closer to the truth
based on what I saw if that was true I
think it was true
so people say well that's just a dying
brain or something I wasn't dying at
that time
the second time I was a motorcycle wreck
but at first time I was
just
falling asleep and it happened
it's weird
but uh that was kind of the world that
that I saw
and it seems to be kind of universal
every other explanation or every other
story of Obe and nde sounds real similar
to what I to what I experienced
it's weird you guys will see it
eventually
Zach said I have PTSD from that
hairstyle because I grew up watching
reruns of Full House and the guitar
player dude had that same damn haircut a
lot of people do have that same day
America Danny Rowling said yeah the guy
in the suit actually see the ghost or
just feel the ghost walking through them
I think the implication was that he just
felt it walking through him and he was
like what the [ __ ] like it felt like
really weird but guys I thought the
implication was that only Eddie saw it
and he was the only one that's on he's
like oh well that's why that guy turned
around like what the [ __ ] you know what
I mean because my what must that feel
like a little ghost going through your
body you know what I mean so yeah I
think that he just felt that
uh so yeah so then they moved to Tempe
Arizona uh fun fact the house in this
episode looks very similar to our old
house yeah the one we were living in um
except for the entrance was like more
like wider and more elaborate like it
had like an arch over it and the same
layout it was the same company you could
tell it was the same company and the
garage layout was a little bit different
like it was similar but ours had like a
little garage like on this side of the
house we had two garages
yeah yeah this one this one had two on
this side and then known on this side
and we had like one big one on this side
and one little one on this yeah we had
two car garage and a one-car garage yeah
but that's but it was kind of but other
than that it was like the similar layout
and the thing about it is that I don't
know
because as with a lot of the houses on
this show I'm not sure if the exterior
and the interior were shot in the same
house you know what I'm saying so it
might not be
because the interior of the house kind
of looked like ours but not exactly like
the same setup
you know yeah
um let's see where was I like you think
they were actually filming inside that
house that they were showing from the
outside or if they just I doubt it they
don't usually they were just using
establishing shots yeah I mean any kind
of like any time you have any movie or
TV show or something it's very very rare
that they use the same interior they do
sometimes but usually they have
different needs you know for the outside
and the inside and they don't usually
have the same house that meets those
needs so they usually shoot them in two
different places a lot of times they'll
shoot Interiors like on a set although I
don't know if this one was shot on a
Saturn you guys could hit the like
button we'd much appreciate it that
would help us out yeah yeah always yeah
always do that don't forget to do that
you always hit the like button we can
always give super chats you know how
Jenny loves them super chats
laughs
all right I had to pass the collection
plate around yeah don't forget oh
everybody's broke it's the end of the
month in the in the end of the year is
coming holidays are coming
yeah I know everybody's got to buy
presents and [ __ ]
I'm just gonna buy you a present and I'm
gonna buy Pokey a present yeah
okay that'll probably be about it yeah
it's not gonna be a present heavy year I
don't think man that is [ __ ] well
honestly it's bad news yeah and it's
honestly I can't really a lot of times I
can't think of anything
like that I really really want like I
can but I don't know it's just like a
lot of times I'm just like oh I really
really need this thing you know what I
mean
I can think of a couple things but I'm
not really
uh so yeah
so Eddie sets up a studio in the new
house everything seems like it's gonna
be awesome they just love this new house
they love the city they love living out
in the desert and they're basically like
yeah we just planned to stay in this
house for like a really long time you
know what I mean
now a few weeks later Eddie starts
working on a new album and he tends to
like to work like really late at night
like when his wife and son are asleep
because it's quiet in the house and you
know there aren't any distractions and
[ __ ] like that
so while he's working in the studio he
hears something outside the studio like
it sounds like somebody is like [ __ ]
around or like moving around like out in
the house
now at first he thinks it's his wife or
you know maybe his son like in the
kitchen or whatever but then he starts
thinking well maybe somebody broke in
like it sounds like an intruder so he
goes to check and he doesn't see
anything like he's looking around like
all the doors are locked all the windows
are locked and you know and intact and
everything like that now there is a jump
scare here with a mean old man ghost
like peering in the window but Eddie
didn't say he saw that like he didn't
see anything at this time he just said
he thought someone was in the house
because he heard something but then he
went out when he went out there like
nobody was there so he thought that was
really weird so you know but they have
to put the little jump scare in there
so over the next in like the ensuing
weeks Eddie's working on his album Myrna
gets a job as she's a teacher and uh
junior Gets a Job his name's Eddie too
but I'm just going to call him Junior to
avoid confusion uh he gets a job
managing a large chain drugstore I'm
assuming CBS or Walgreens or something
like that
now later this one evening Junior comes
home from work and he's also been like
playing basketball with some of his
buddies after so he goes in his room and
crashes out on the bed without taking a
shower or anything and I'm just like
he's all sweaty from basketball and he's
like he's getting that all over his
comforter
because these are the kind of things I
think about when I'm watching this like
I know he did a really just coming for
basketball because he's an actor but
it's like in the context of the story I
was like gross you're just gonna like
lay down there like all sweaty yeah
so yeah so he lays down the bed like uh
to watch some baseball on TV
but then he starts feeling like really
really weird like he can't breathe and
like his heart starts he said he it felt
like his heart was like gonna pop out
his chest like it was just like
palpitating so he starts like rolling
around on the floor
um and he said it felt like he was
having a heart attack and I think at
this point like he's only in his 20s
like he's really young I think let's see
Pokey she's like sneezing over there
so uh they don't really know what's the
matter so Myrna calls an ambulance and
he gets taken to a hospital block frog
said jump scare huh sounds like a later
episode yeah I don't know if I'd
necessarily call it a jump scare because
it wasn't like blah like there wasn't a
loud noise or anything but they did kind
of do that thing where the guy was like
oh I don't see anything and then he
turned away and then they were like oh
there's like actually like an old ghost
guy looking in the window even though
you know the guy wasn't looking at it so
I feel like they did that like through
the whole run of a haunting now later on
they did have the whole thing like they
have in like shitty horror movies where
they made like the big Musical sing but
this one didn't have that they were just
showing a lot of stuff that the guy said
that he didn't see you know what I mean
didn't say that he saw it rather
so they take Junior to the hospital so
doctors run a whole shitload of tests
but they can't find anything physically
wrong with him so they just assume that
he's had a panic attack which to be
honest with you that's kind of what it
sounded like to me too
um they're saying they're like yeah but
usually he's just like so chill and
everything but they're like yeah but you
know you guys just moved and he had a
new job maybe he stressed out because of
that and he's not really like dealing
with it or whatever so
um they just prescribed this very mild
sedative and they said what you should
do is keep um start keeping a journal so
that whenever you start to feel like
that again like you'll know what
emotions or events uh you know it is
that triggers it so we'll be able to
maybe kind of like pinpoint you know how
to fix it
so over the next month or so Junior
keeps having these attacks
and he keeps going back to doctors
presumably because they keep saying we
took kept taking him to doctors but the
doctors can't figure out what's wrong
with him like there doesn't seem to be
anything physically wrong with him
um now there are some scenes kind of put
in here where he seems to be having
visions of this old guy like the old guy
that was in the window like and also
like a swastika flag but he didn't say
he saw that so I guess that was kind of
like foreshadowing uh there's also a
little bit where his eyes go white for a
second like the cab drivers did at the
beginning
so they said that his health started
getting worse and worse
um he can't work so I'm assuming he
either like took sick leave or they
fired him or whatever
um and they said he got to a point where
he didn't even leave the house he
basically stayed in his room with the
curtains closed and like stayed in bed
all the time and he's basically like on
a really cranky like any time anybody
comes in like to try to check on him
he's like [ __ ] off leave me alone blah
blah blah like he's a you know he gets
really mad which is like unlike him
um so Eddie the dad he's like we were
getting really frustrated because we
kept going to doctors and nobody could
figure out what was the matter with him
and he's like after that he's like I
even called out like the dude from the
gas company like an electrician like the
a lead poisoning expert guy like people
like that like to see if there was
something wrong with the house that was
like making him act that way so it's
like it seemed like he was you know kind
of covering all the bases like to see if
there was some reason because they
couldn't find any um cause for it
otherwise
so one night
Eddie's in the kitchen and he's kind of
making like a really nice dinner for
everybody and Junior is in his room
writing in his journal
now in the kitchen like Eddie is
listening to the radio and the radio
suddenly starts to go like all staticky
like somebody's changing the state like
an invisible person is like changing the
stations
um so Eddie goes over there like what
the [ __ ] and it's like adjusting the
radio and then he turns around again and
all of the cabinets and drawers are wide
open like in the kitchen like suddenly
yeah show them open they're just they
just are he just turns around and like
it's all open which like I said I would
[ __ ] a brick if I turned around and all
that happened that would be like [ __ ]
freaky but yeah so it was like
apparently it was like immediate
so when he saw that he's like um okay so
maybe this whole thing that Junior is
going through maybe this is Paranormal
you know what I mean it seems like this
is the first inkling that he has that
maybe this isn't
you know that this is like a
supernatural cause
meanwhile in Junior's room
he starts going all white-eyed and
starts like spaced out and what is
actually like a pretty effective because
they have like his eyes are just like
all white like with contact lenses and
he's just like kind of sitting there
going ah like that and it's like pretty
freaky looking I thought like it they
did a good job of it and he starts
writing the name Rick like over and over
in his notebook like across multiple
Pages like you just he writes it all
like many many pages
now when he snaps out of it like several
minutes later presumably he can't he
like looks down like what the [ __ ] like
he didn't remember doing that and he
shows his dad he's like dude that's like
not even my handwriting so I don't even
know what the [ __ ] is going on so at
this point Eddie's like I'm pretty sure
that this is a ghost and that's what it
is that's causing
Junior's illness
now the next morning Junior comes in the
kitchen
while his parents are like sitting at
the table having breakfast and his mom
notices these two kind of quarter-sized
burns on Junior's lower back and Junior
does not know how they got there they
don't really go more into it than that
they just kind of bring that up but they
don't mention it again so you know
there's just like burns on there which
is unusual because usually in these kind
of stories it's like three little claw
marks but today it was Burns
so Eddie decides to get to the bottom of
this he's gonna check into the history
of the house
and he's wondering if anybody else has
had any trouble with ghosts or with this
specific entity I guess
so he goes and talks to his neighbor now
the neighbor says
um you know well you can't really talk
to the previous guy who lived here
because he's dead
um and it's rumored that he committed
suicide
the neighbor also said oh but she might
be in luck though because the guy's
daughter actually just lives down the
street like on the corner and you can
probably go down there and ask her and
maybe she knows some [ __ ] that could
help you out
Ben says I really should watch this show
sometimes so I know what you all are
talking about
I mean yeah it would help it's a fun
watch it would help but yeah they're fun
they're fun
uh Danny Rowling said the boombox that
was in the kitchen to this episode can
also be seen in the Sally House episode
on a bookshelf uh I also I own the same
one yeah
I'm sure they reused like some of the
props
block frog said gotta love when they
show you things they say they didn't
they say they didn't even see yeah
I and I always and I'm always like
really sensitive to that you know what I
mean like how
they'll show faces when they didn't say
they saw that yeah or they'll show like
some [ __ ] like lurking around behind the
person when the person's just kind of
like walking through the thing it's like
there's ghosty [ __ ] back there and I get
what they're getting at like they're
sort of like trying to visually manifest
that it's like oh the person said that
they felt like someone was in the house
but they didn't say that they saw
somebody creeping around like that yeah
just like they keep showing like Nazi
flags and imageries and stuff around
this dude nobody ever said they saw that
and um they're not saying the guy was a
Nazi it was just racist guy
well he would like yeah his mom I get or
his mom his daughter that's completely
different uh I guess his daughter was
saying was implying that he got into
like some white power group like in
prison or something he's a prisoner yeah
ex-con yeah so I yeah I guess that's
kind of what they were implying and she
did say that he had a flag up there on
the wall like that
but I don't know if that's exactly what
the flag looked like so who knows
uh so yeah so Eddie goes to This Woman's
house her name is Joan actually
and he knocks on the door Aryan Nation
is what they're talking about I mean
it's specifically it yeah it's probably
that I've seen that other symbol because
there was a swastika on there and then
there was that other symbol and then it
said so it said www.p like something
something white power and I can't like
remember yeah like I know what I've seen
that before but I don't remember what it
is
um okay so Eddie goes to This Woman's
house like I said her name is Joan and
knocks on the door now she seems
friendly at first because he's like hey
I'm your neighbor um I bought the house
that your dad used to live in and then
she seems to be like oh oh you know what
I mean and then
um he's like I I need to ask you
something about your dad and she kind of
starts to shut the door in his face like
nope got [ __ ] to do
um it's like no I really have to talk to
you about your father Rick and my son is
getting really sick and I think that
your dad is like haunting the house you
know what I mean and then she gets like
roll kind of aggro and she says I don't
know what you're talking about my dad's
name was Christopher
um good day sir it's like that kind of
thing and she like slams the [ __ ]
door
so at this point like Eddie doesn't know
what to do he's like okay so I'm barking
up the wrong tray I'm out of leads now I
don't really know
uh what I'm gonna do now because
apparently the spirit world is like way
more powerful than I thought and I'm not
going to be able to do anything to help
Junior you know what I mean
so he goes into the kitchen one night uh
I guess he goes in there like to get a
snack or some [ __ ] like that and when
he's like looking in the fridge and then
when he turns around he sees the kind of
old guy standing there like staring all
hateful at him right now apparently at
first like he thinks it's a real guy
because so it must have looked like a
real person because he basically tells
the guy hey just take whatever you want
just don't like you know hurt my family
or whatever but then the dude like walks
across the kitchen and like vanishes
into like a cabinet or like into the
pantry or something like he goes through
the door so obviously it's a [ __ ]
ghost that's [ __ ] ghost that's been
like causing all this trouble all this
time
so at this point Eddie decides okay well
I need some outside help
so he goes on the internet and he
contacts the Arizona desert Ghost
Hunters
and that weekend
um the team comes out it's like the the
founder of it like Ann Martin she comes
I think she was on the show like the
real lady and then they also bring this
other lady whose name I can't remember
but she was like a Tarot reader type of
person I think her the real her was on
the show too and then there was another
guy but he wasn't on the show he was
just like the guy taking pictures or
whatever so they start like taking
digital photos and doing like EVP
recordings like who are you blah blah
they're doing all that kind of stuff now
the tarot lady they have a little thing
where they're doing a little tarot
session and she says it first she got
like the hanged man and she's like oh
that indicates suicide and then she got
the Ten of Swords somebody not moving on
which you know and then Eddie says he
was like well what's the guy's name I
guess like maybe testing her and she
didn't say Rick but she did say his name
started with r like so she got that much
right anyway
um and then she said that he basically
wants all of us out of here like
including all of you guys and he doesn't
want us here either
so she wants to perform a ritual to get
rid of this [ __ ] and uh you know
which entails like you know essentially
smudging the house with sage so that's
what they do that particular night
now this seems to work at first
um as it usually does
because immediately after that the
spirit seems to be gone like all of the
psychics and stuff are and there's like
oh we don't sense them anymore and over
the next couple days the family said
they didn't notice anything weird
happening like there was no Paranormal
Activity nothing like that and Junior
seems to be recovering like he seems to
be getting better and like acting normal
again
one night a few days later though uh
Eddie is in his studio and he hears
Junior like screaming from the other
room like from his bedroom turns out
he's screaming at his mom like to leave
him alone like get off my back like he's
like flipping out and the mom is like
he's acting like super scary and super
aggressive like saying all kind of
horrible [ __ ] to her which is completely
unlike him and he's just acting all
[ __ ] crazy now the show did have him
speaking in like a demon voice but I
don't know if that's what really
happened but they did have him kind of
like yelling like normal but then he was
just like you know what I mean so I
don't know about that
um and then oh and I also put the note
Junior looks like kylo Ren by the way
well I had forgotten about it until I
was re-watching the episode and I was
like oh yeah I did say it looked like
kylo Ren didn't he because like I said I
watched the episode we watched the
episode last night and then I watched it
again today like to take notes
so
um at this point uh you know Eddie is
just kind of like okay well I'm gonna
try that [ __ ] that my mom did like back
in the day when that crazy guy like got
dragged in the house like the exorcism
deal
so he starts throwing holy water on
Junior and Junior of course is screaming
like it burns it burns you know what I
mean because he's seen the extras too
just like we all have and then Eddie
does the whole glass of water on the
head ritual you know what I mean like
putting the glass on the thing and
trapping the thing and doing the thing
with the head and all that kind of stuff
now um so apparently again this seems to
work they said so Junior like starts
acting completely normal afterward and
he seemingly doesn't remember anything
that happened prior to that because he's
like wakes up he's like what the [ __ ]
going on you know what I mean it's that
kind of thing
now uh so everything seems fine after
that uh Eddie finished his album they
had like this big kind of like party
celebration like with a cake and
champagne and [ __ ] like that several
days later Joan who is the neighbor lady
like the the [ __ ] ghost's daughter
yes yeah
she comes over and she apologizes for
like turning him away before
and she says um you know I kind of lied
a little bit or stretched the truth a
little bit she said yes my dad's name
was Christopher but his middle name was
Richard and his closest friends and
family did call him Rick but nobody else
did so she's like so some people did
call him Rick
she said that he went to prison for a
long time and when he got out he had a
hard time adjusting I'm like is that
what we're calling it now like that he's
basically like a [ __ ] raging white
supremacist yeah that's a hard time
adjusting he's a hard time adjusting
there's probably more to it than that
I'm yeah I'm just saying that it's like
well I mean I'm just going by I'm just
being funny like by what they're
presenting to us because I was like that
seems like a little more than hard time
adjusting
um now Joan actually rented him the
house like hoping that it would help him
out but obviously that we all know how
that worked out
so Jones says can I go up to my dad's
old room which is I think I mean the
show implies like that's where he died
right like whether he committed suicide
or not they think that he did but um at
least on the show they had it look like
he killed himself in that room
so he goes up to the father's old room
which is actually Junior's room now
and she's kind of wigged out because
she's looking at all Junior stuff and
she's like all the furniture is in the
same places as where her dad had it's
not the same Furniture obviously but
it's in like the same positions like the
bed's in the same position the dresser's
in the same position and she's like and
look there's even a flag over the bed in
the same place as her dad had a flag
although obviously like in Junior's room
it's like a Puerto Rican flag and when
Dad was here it was like a white power
flag situation with a swastika on it a
big difference you know what I mean
um and it's also implied although they
don't say this outright but it's implied
that she was the one that found him dead
on the floor of this room I don't know
if that's really what happened but
that's kind of what they portrayed but
they didn't say it overtly
so basically Jones says to the family
um you know I guess the reason that Dad
is hanging around in this house being a
douche is because he's just like a big
fat angry racist who doesn't like Puerto
Ricans living in his house essentially
that's like the only reason
um now Joan is like flipping through
photos that the Ghost Hunters took
earlier like when they were there and in
one of the pictures she see I think it
was of um was supposed to be like of Ann
Martin like the the founder of the group
she sees what looks like her dad's face
like behind one of the team but it's
like kind of you know what I mean it's
kind of like [ __ ] just like single
color like kind of white gray back there
um now of course they didn't show the
real picture because the woman that was
it was the actress that was playing the
thing so I'm sure like the real photo
wasn't as impressive as that although
they did say yeah we saw the photo and
it looked like her dad's face in it but
I didn't see like what the real photo
looked like so I don't know like
obviously the one that they showed on
the show like looked really scary
because it looked exactly like the real
dude
now uh Weeks Later Eddie is lying on the
couch reading the newspaper and he said
he started to feel really really weird
like he was having a heart attack he was
like he started trembling all over he
was like having a hard time breathing
feeling like he was dying he said so he
basically like falls under the floor and
like goes unconscious they do kind of
like show like the the [ __ ] goes like
flashing before him like haha I'm
killing you [ __ ] but it's like
he didn't say he saw that so he just
goes unconscious now he's in a coma for
three days although the doctors
apparently cannot figure out why
now after three days he supposedly
miraculously just like wakes up like out
of nowhere
and he actually when he woke up and he
was fine Apparently after that and he
said that he believed that Rick had
tried to kill him
and because of this because he was like
well there's just no way this is just
going to escalate or get worse and if he
can do that then he can hurt any one of
us so he's like we need to move out of
the house so they actually did end up
moving out of the house
um I don't know where they went
subsequently
uh so after that there's like there's a
little jump scare at the end with uh
good old ghostly racist Rick jumping out
at us from like an empty bedroom they
kind of show like The Empty bedroom like
ooh spooky like everybody moved out and
then they kind of like flash on it like
it was when racist Rick was there and
then he just like kind of comes over the
camera like like that and then it's like
roll credits so that's like the end of
Casa de los Muertos yeah so
I mean of all the reasons to hang around
being a ghost
really I mean this is really one of the
most pitiful
I have to say it was an entertaining
episode it was uh for me it wasn't all
that compelling there wasn't a lot of
physical phenomena uh mentioned it was
mostly just kind of like stories of what
somebody saw or what they thought and
just I don't know just there wasn't a
lot of moving objects not very many
witnesses in it
you know or maybe it's just the way that
this the story was shown it just didn't
seem to be
that dramatic
it's a lot of it was just open to
interpretation
well I kind of feel like that's evidence
that's true of like a lot of the
episodes I mean especially the ones that
deal with possession because even though
this one wasn't about like technically
demon possession it was more like a
ghost possession it's more like a person
that was you know haunting the [ __ ]
um
I kind of do feel like a lot of it is
subjective yes yeah
you know what I mean like in some and a
lot of the ghost ones you know like oh
yeah we went there and all the all the
windows were nailed shut for some reason
and we unnailed them and then the
windows kept opening and you know just
there's just more anecdotal
uh you know stories of uh things that
physically moved
you know there does not a lot of it in
this
yeah and this like the cabinets and the
drawers opening that's about it that was
about it and he did say that he heard
noises like someone was in the house but
no one was there like other than that he
didn't even see any apparitions from
what I can remember
yeah he did he did see an apparition
okay yeah he saw he saw the he saw a
racist ricklet standing right there in
the kitchen okay all right and he
thought it was a real person how many
times did he see that just that one time
and he said it walked into the into the
cabinet because he thought it was a real
person and then like it walked across
and like walked into the door and like
kind of went through the door okay you
know what I mean all right I think he's
the only one that saw it though but like
I said they kind of established that he
could see dead people don't see dead
people right so you know because they
kind of set that up earlier like when
you before they moved out to Arizona
like he saw that guy walking through
that other dude right it's an
entertaining episode it is yeah well a
lot of them are they usually take even
if the stories because some of the
stories you can tell that they are kind
of thin and so they're kind of like
trying to pad them out and like make but
I you know it's they gotta make an
episode
um you know and everybody knows like
it's watching it it's just like
entertainment value they're not trying
to be like a scientific Treatise or
anything like that so
you know they did claim that they had a
photograph didn't they yeah I said that
yeah yeah yeah like we're you know I'm
just talking about more evidence that
they have yeah they didn't show the real
one they just showed like but yeah the
the daughter said that they one of the
pictures that the ghost team took right
it looked like her dad's face was in it
I'd like to see the real photo
yeah Zach said uh you keep saying racist
Rick and in my mind's eye I'm just
seeing Rick from Dan Bell's videos well
you know what's funny about that is when
we were watching the episode last night
and when Junior started writing Rick
Rick Rick like in his notebook I even
said out loud I'm like oh my God he's
being haunted by Rick Sarah
from Danville from the Danville show
from another dirty room test your toilet
seat
yeah turn your mattress upside down look
at the bed bugs
and then he'll eat your hotel soap right
you'll find all the [ __ ] Splash
everywhere
that's semen right there
using the black light and [ __ ] [ __ ]
funny that show is like I mean Dan Bell
does a lot of different shows but I
think another dirty broom are my
favorite even though like every time I
watch them it's just like on a barf all
over myself oh my God they're so [ __ ]
gross and it's like I don't even know
how I don't even know how they do it how
they do that show like without throwing
up forever because there's just no way
and a couple times like Dan has been
like like he was Heathen but it's like
dude I would be puking Daisy says we
deserves more views yes and I know we do
thank you very much deserve all kinds of
views
you're so modest we don't know why
there's Shadow Banning us all right
we're just a lot there's a lot of
competition on YouTube there is yeah
because honestly even like a lot of
channels that I really like that I
always kind of perceived as being more
popular I was like look and I'm like oh
my God we have more subscribers than
they have if you know what I mean so but
you know but then some channels I I
really like have like a lot more than us
too but a lot of channels that I like
don't have as many as us also
all all algorithms point to to Zach
Friedman every time I'm on there man if
I walk away from a tablet and I come
back eventually it's on Zach Friedman
it's just like this science guy
you ever seen him no if you just let
your [ __ ] roll eventually it'll end up
at Zach Friedman's we'll see but the
thing about it is that it has to do with
what you've watched before yeah so he
talks about everything I guess so when I
eventually maybe you end up at Zach
Friedman I mean honestly because because
of all the [ __ ] that I watch on there
like if you look at all my
recommendations my recommendations are
either gonna be horror movie reviews
obviously or
um hot like people that like look for
Halloween decorations or scary stories
like or true crime or people reading
true crime or scary stories
um also uh extreme budget challenges
like food like people like I fed my
whole family for five dollars this week
and [ __ ] like that because I start I got
obsessed with those for some reason so
now I keep getting man there can't be
any food nutrition in something you
would actually be surprised like what
they can come up with well that's why I
find them interesting because I'm like
wow they got all that with like five
dollars I'm like man good for you I mean
it depends on like where they shop and
stuff too but it's like
because some of them have like some
better
like bargain type stores and where
depending on where they live at you know
what I mean so there's that uh block
frog said I've sampled his voices and my
cartoons before who breaks Sarah yeah
he's like he has his own site too I
don't know if he's streamed lately
every now and then like I watched some
of his streams too but it's like there's
just something about Rick that's really
and I'm on I'm a patron of Dan Bell and
he posts um
podcasts on there that you can't get
anywhere else like just on patreon and
um I just never have time to like listen
to him but some of them sound really
funny like not all of not all of them
have Rick on there but Rick's of Florida
man he is yeah I think he actually lives
in a trailer park
or a mobile home park it may be yeah I
think like him and his wife because they
they stream from their backyard
sometimes like they'll hang out in their
backyard yeah I remember smoking weed
and like having some cocktails correct
me if I'm wrong I think it's a mobile
home park it might be but I can't I
haven't seen it in a long time but it's
like yeah we I always kind of laugh like
whenever they do the [ __ ] another
dirty room because him and his toilet
yeah that's how he says it right he says
yeah he's not from Florida I don't think
I think he moved here
yeah it sounds like it sounds like a
Midwest accent that he has yeah I'm not
sure where he's from originally I wonder
if he has a Wikipedia oh it sounds like
Ohio or something Dan I think Dan said
that he met him at like a ghost hunter
type meeting or meet up or something
like that like that's when we first met
him uh Zach said I still miss Will from
Dan's old videos he's so cute yeah I did
like will I guess him and him and Dan
had a falling out which one was will the
one that was he was the dark-haired one
okay was he the one that was dressed in
drag selling the food on the commercial
that was [ __ ] funny wait was that
well I don't remember who that was oh
maybe yeah because for a time he had
that um he had a sponsor it was like
hellofresh or one of those kind of like
meal kit um type of things didn't dress
up like a woman and he's up there
[ __ ] cooking the food that was yeah I
liked that um I liked that uh that
little sponsorship commercial they did
there because I was like that's pretty
cute the way they did that all right
that might have been well I can't
remember now
um Bob frock said Dan Bell I used the
one audio where he's like it looks like
a horse came in here and ejaculated on
the floor I remember that one yeah
he did a video like quite a while back
where he like put together like his top
10 grossest
like [ __ ] ever and of course I watched
it even though the whole time I was like
in the whole time oh my God it was so
[ __ ] disgusting I can't
I want to watch it but it's just it's
too much it's so [ __ ] gross and I
can't even imagine what it would be like
like being in that place like why would
you do that to yourself and it's like
some of the [ __ ] they come up with it's
like they lift up the mattress and it's
like it looks like somebody [ __ ] just
died on it or pissed all over it it's
like damp and I like to I like the Dan
Bell series one where they go to the old
[ __ ] broken down love motels and all
the old abandoned [ __ ] what was the name
of that yeah that was I like that one
where he went to that one in the Poconos
yeah what was the name of that series
um oh I can't remember but uh another
hotel or another
Another Broken Hotel I don't remember
what it's called
but uh you can find it on Dan Bell's
Channel
that's where he goes to all those old
abandoned hotels it's pretty good
although I have to say my favorite
another dirty room was where they went
to that one I think it was in Florida
that had all the themed rooms and they
stayed in like that Jungle Room yeah
they liked that one though which
actually wasn't too no they said it
wasn't too dirty which but like I said
they said it caught they said it cost
like 200 something dollars and I don't
like it better be [ __ ] clean for 200
you know because some of the ones they
stay in that are filthy are like you
know 200 a night that are like 50 60
bucks
um you know then they look like a
[ __ ] crack Hotel yeah 200 a night
that's ridiculous it's more that it was
more than that I think it was 230 or 250
or something like that and I was like
well that's too much even for that but
it better but it better be clean if I'm
paying that much yeah 200 bucks you can
get a nice room yeah
almost like a mini apartment for a night
Zach says didn't they get a few places
shut down because of their vids uh it
wouldn't Shock Me and honestly some of
those places deserve to get shut oh yeah
you want to stand there man holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] roaches everywhere
yeah [ __ ] crack pipes and yeah bags
of dirty panties like underneath the
beds yeah like Piggy flip over the
mattress and there's like big blood
stains and [ __ ] stains there are hooker
hotels crack hookers yeah I mean clearly
yeah it was just I'd be scared to stay
in most of those places to be honest
with you all right you seem like you
wanna
blame it on me no I just say you just
you did that it was over you did that
ending sign
aren't you hungry a little bit yeah
um or something oh that sounds good um
all right so tomorrow is Tuesday which
means we're gonna do another matinee so
we got to figure out another movie to do
um what do you want to do a new one or
you want to do an old one do you want to
do like I said you want to do so we ran
out we're ran out of movies well we
could do yeah we did watch
um the thing from another world yeah do
you want to talk about that yeah we'll
just do that okay yeah because we
watched that the other night because we
were curious like to see because I'd
never watched the whole thing straight
through like the one yeah so we can
actually do that because if we watch a
movie we'll talk about it
yeah yeah I mean no sense of waste of
the movie that we watched no sense
wasting time wasting a movie yeah yeah
because that fits right in with the
universal stuff I don't think that is a
universal monster but no it's it ties in
with the crystal sphere
and uh that you know
it's Crystal sphere yeah sure and like I
said I hadn't seen it uh all the way
through so I thought it was like it's a
pretty good movie it is pretty good it's
not as good it's not as good as the
Remake but it's pretty good well no I
mean very few movies are as good as the
thing it's got a lot of 50 stuff in it
it's very 50s yeah Danny Rowling said
night of the Comet we will get around to
doing night of the combat one of these
days and shopping mall tail because
actually shopping mall I think is free
on the 2B and actually night of the
Comet might be too or I think it's on uh
shutter all right so thank you all for
dropping by for our haunting Mondays so
we will be back tomorrow probably
talking about the thing from another
world unless we think of something else
to do
um but yeah so have a good rest of your
evening you guys and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow good night